comment vous avez réussi à infiltrer
cette boîte vous êtes rentré comme ça
dure et non pas du coup dans le cadre du
reportage pour rtl j'ai fait des
recherches sur les réseaux
principalement instagram et ça m'a mené
en fait un promoteur de boîte de nuit
qui que j'ai contactés et kim hakim a
donc accepté dans cette soirée j'ai
demandé si besoin j'ai amené des je suis
venu accompagner parce que ben c'est un
peu bizarre d'aller en boîte de nuit sur
celle qui avec des amis la prochaine
fois venez guillaume genton non mais
sérieux le cadre du reportage très très
content alors donc vous y allez là bas
comment ça se passe à l'entrée alors à
l'entrée du coup j'arrive c'est vraiment
c'est un immeuble comme les autres enfin
en deux devant on dirait pas du tout en
établissement comme ça quoi et puis donc
il ya un videur qui entrouvre la porte
qui me demandent mon nom qui vérifie que
j'ai sur la liste évidemment que moi on
connaît pas mon visage suis pas une
habituée donc on me dit ok tu peux
rentrer mais il faut payer une bouteille
à 300 euros c'est le prix du ticket de
ru
à la bouteille d'orangina
300 pages web en fait pour les non
habitués parce qu'il y en a qui rentrent
en train de dire que rtl a payé 300
euros
on est donc vous avez payé la bouteille
d'eau coupé la route et profond euros
voilà et du coup donc je rentre et en
fait donc là il ya on descend c'est en
sous sol et donc à deux grandes salles
en enfilade est donc là il ya tout un
énorme barre
des serveurs des barmans un dj enfin
maintenant en fait tous les éléments
d'une boîte de nuit es6 cambrai c'est
dans un immeuble normal quoi bah en tout
cas de dole depuis la rue en face à
dwayne dialogue saint just aux barrières
manuelles ou rien du tout ou rien du
tout pas de passes sanitaire fin oui pas
de masque à aucun contrôle aucun
contrôle à l'intérieur vraiment on
rentre on rentre comme dans une boîte de
nuit comme une soirée normale quoi alors
cocher quoi la légion qui avait là bas
parce que c'est cher quand même 300 mal
oui après ben moi c'est pour moi j'étais
jeune à bitche et personne ne connaît
pas beaucoup payé 300 pages mai
la clientèle c'est des jeunes en
principalement 25 30 ans
elle avait posé une question comprenait
moulin bol si vous voulez vous réveiller
non mais si vous êtes là pour écouter
julie
voilà juste sous la halle aux vins aux
petites pancartes sinon voila merci je
pense que si je voulais donner de telle
heure là il va si vous n'avez pas la
question ne répondait pas
parce qu'elle est déjà connu on parle on
parle de politique
voilà donc dans ces soirées comprenez
vous le ras bol des
métallos
man toi le cul oui alors vraiment mais
je vais dévoiler l'identité de personnes
mais l ambition mais il y avait il y
avait des jeunes j'ai croisé des stars
de la télé réalité et j'ai croisé du
coup il y avait 1 j'ai croisé un jeune
homme qui était engagé en politique et
voilà gens connus que ceux qui parlent
et qu'ils aillent voir mais il paraît
qu'il y avait plusieurs politiques ont
voté à droite à gauche à moi je moi je
sais pas moi j'ai croisé un jeune engagé
en politique voilà je peux pas je peux
pas vous en dire plus et personne du
gouvernement non hein mais je pose la
question maintenant nom de mes infos
personnes du gouvernement c'est plus
sévère qu'ils parlent nos jeunes en
effet tout irait on appelle directement
sur imams et des noms vous à leur gauche
il est alors plutôt à gauche à un
mélenchon ne trompe
pas en bois qu'ils avec moins de mains
et qu'on aperçoit démission devant lui
que l'on est pas de bêtises droit dont
n'ont pas un peu moins un peu moins
gauche - goût hidalgo non
et pourquoi hidalgo elle elle passe
directement par un tunnel
faisait pendant bois tu crois quoi
chercher sondage selena gomez
voilà je suis cheveux c'est bon voilà un
amateur de montres pas du tout non non
c'est pas quelqu'un de connu c'est
quelqu'un doit l'annoncer
premier plan quoi c'est non pas de
premier plan de comm ca de second plan